Here's an overview of the changes
we're going to be making to Sunshine.
We'll continue to refer to this map
as we move these coding exercises.
There are lots of terms in this map
that we haven't discussed before
such as database contract,
content provider, and DB Helper.
Each one of these blocks represents
a section of our modular
data storage solution.
We start by defining our data
storage in terms of a contract.
We then implement
the database using SQLite.
And finally, we layer a fundamental
Android class between our UI and
the data storage called
a content provider.
Ultimately, building our data storage
in this way allows Sunshine to leverage
powerful Android frameworks.
We'll explain all of this in more
detail as we implement each section.
Let's get started.